When evaluating expressions, it's important that we use parentheses. I didn't
use parentheses on that last quiz, because I only had two variables, and one
operation between them. But we should always use parentheses when replacing
variables. Here's why. Here's an expression of triangles and circles. One thing
that we want to be careful about, is what's the operation between symbols and
numbers? Well, we assume that there's multiplication between variables, or
symbols, and numbers. We don't often show it in algebra, but we want to make
sure that we always include that there. We'll see other examples of this later
throughout the course. I'm going to assign a value of the triangles to be
negative 1. And I'm going to assign the values of the circles to be 3. We
want to use parenthesis when we replace variables because of negative sign.
Here's what it would look like. I would have 3 times negative 1, because the
triangle is negative 1. Then times 3, because a circle is 3 plus 4 times
negative 1 again for the triangle. And it's squared. And then times 3, for the
circle. And on the end, I would have minus negative 1. To the third. Here, this
circle is really an exponent. So I have 3 times negative 1 times 3, which is
negative 9. I know negative 1 squared is negative 1 times negative 1. Negative
1 times negative 1 is just positive 1. So I have negative 9, then plus, and
then I have 4 times 1 times 3, which is 12. Now, on this end part here, I have
to do negative 1 cubed first. I know powers come first. I've rewritten the
statement over here, so now negative 1 cubed is really negative 1 times
negative 1 times negative 1. I know three negative 1s make up negative 1, the
first two would be positive 1, then I'd make it negative. So I have negative 9
plus 12, subtracting a negative is really adding a positive. Negative nine plus
12 is three, plus one, is four. When I plug in the value of negative one for my
triangles, and when I plug in the value of three for the circles, I get an
answer of four.